(guitar music)
- Day off all to myself.
- Day off to myself.
- What to do.
(whistling)
(screaming)
You're supposed to be at work.
- You're supposed to be
in clothes, what the-
- This is the female form Garrick.
God.
(rock music)
No.
- I got here first, it's only fair.
- I took today off first Garrick.
- No, I told you weeks ago
I was taking today off.
- When?
- The same day I bought this cape.
(upbeat rock music)
- Well, you never told me that.
- Yes I did.
- No, Garrick you didn't,
I would have remembered.
- Are you sure I didn't tell
you when you were asleep,
actually when I say that out
loud that does sound bad.
- You talk to me in my sleep?
- Sometimes.
Kate your mom called, she
said her flight was delayed.
Hop to it.
Hey Kate, you got a parking ticket.
I'm just gonna put it in a
drawer next to the other ones.
Hey Kate,
the one who got away he's outside
and he's ready to commit.
He said if you don't love him, do nothing
and he'll leave you alone forever.
So.
- Tim was here.
I should have stopped the wedding.
- You sleep a lot.
- Well, let's just agree to pretend
that the other one isn't here today.
- You mean like I do everyday?
- That was a mean thing to say.
Are you saying that-
- What are you doing?
Why are you?
Come one don't.
- You just said that (crying).
- Here, here, here, take the remote.
Take the remote, take it.
- Strategy.
- Oh my God, damn those white woman tears.
- Yeah I know.
Ah crap.
Hey Garrick.
- Looking for this?
- Our only spoon.
20 piece utensil set or 20 pack of sporks?
- [Kate] Sporks.
Are you almost done?
- Nope.
- Well then why'd you let me pour the milk
in my cereal if-
- I could be done
if I got the remote.
- I'll just use the ladle, I don't care.
Ladle's like a,
ladle's like a big spoon anyway.
So that's what I'm just gonna use,
I'm just gonna use, shoot.
- There it is, you got.
- A little bit of this.
- Looks like a lot of effort.
- Mixing down,
it's not even a hiccup in my-
- That work?
Working out for ya?
- Oh no, okay.
Give me the spoon.
- Thank you.
Strategy.
- Oh my God.
(laughter)
You're a,
you're a real piece of shit.
Yard sale down the street was getting rid
of this perfectly good drum set.
I was like, well,
got nothing else to do today.
Might as well work on
my rhythm of the night.
(drum and symbol beats)
One and two and three and four and five.
(screams and loud guitar music)
Go away!
Two, three, four!
- I'm so loud.
(screaming)
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Are we great at this?
- You tell me.
(guitar music)
(symbol crash)
We're so good.
- Yeah.
That is good.
What about Garrick and the Rest?
- What about Kate and Company?
- Mudslinging.
- Dirt Mistake.
- Eyelash.
- Rain.
- Chubby Bunnies.
- According to Your Mom but
the two is a roman numeral two.
- Weird Bottles.
- Tree Scare.
- Changified.
- Deep Ear.
- Baby Skulls.
- Star Gatherer.
- What Happened to Nelly.
- Stop It.
- Poop Emoji.
- Popped Pimple.
- Uneven Sleeves.
- Who about Loose Tooth McGee.
- Dick Picks.
- Ingrown Hair.
- Baby Feet.
- Wood Paneling.
- Uh Oh, Here Come that Man.
- Worm.
- Pencil Fingers.
- Ding Dong
(studdering) Ditch.
- Period Sex.
- Dressing Room.
- Bloated.
- Cars?
- The Space Between Your Eyes.
- Bowel Syndrome.
- Empty Swimming Pool.
- The Part in that Dream
When you Can't Run Away
But You Feel Like You Have to Run
But You're Only Running in Slow Motion,
You're Carrying a Sleeping
Bag That You Don't Own.
- Flaccid Penis.
- Out of Toilet Paper.
- Erect Penis?
- Caaaall,
like eight a's.
- Umm,
I like Plugs.
(symbols crashing)